we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p here is sometimes talking
points just spread like a virus and
nobody actually examines the content of
them here's one example about polling
take a listen david's josh from virginia
i was just curious
i had heard that a majority of the polls
for presidential candidates are done
over landlines and i was wondering
does that give it a more of an older
voter influence on those polls rather a
majority of people and the younger ages
are having cell phones i wasn't sure i
had heard that the majority of them were
done over landlines and those just cured
her still on your your take on that
anyway thanks for your show i just
awesome keep up the good work
so the general talking point is that
polling is very establishment centric
because they are over sampling older
folks who are who tend to be more
establishment or on the right even
within the democratic party the older
folks tend to be more establishment they
are using landlines which tends to be
more older folks than younger folks that
have them
you really got a look at it poll by poll
but generally speaking this isn't the
case when i looked at a bunch of the
recent polls most of them are sampling
older folks in proportion to their
representation in the population
adjusted slightly for the fact that
older folks are actually more likely to
go out and vote so you do need to adjust
the sample slightly on that basis the
economists YouGov poll that we talked
about earlier today did not use
landlines it was using web-based
interviews i get calls on my mobile
phone all the time from the from
pollsters all the time i mean it you
know every few months or something like
that so no it you you can look at the
methodology for each poll um and it i
don't think it serves us to criticize
polls for reasons that aren't good ones
there are many ways in which we can add
caveats and nuance to our understanding
of polling but there's a lot of people
who just are saying it's all fake
because they use all landlines and our
polling mostly old people this
just isn't true in general and I
encourage you to look at the
methodologies of polls to confirm it for
yourself don't take my word for it I
mean really don't we've got a great
bonus show for you today get access to
the bonus show by becoming a member or a
patron at join pakman.com or patreon.com
slash david pakman show